I'm joined today by David Keith who is
professor of engineering and of public
policy at Harvard University you've
worked in the fields of climate science
energy technology you've been in public
policy it's so interesting now what we
are seeing with regard to it I think
that geoengineering is sort of crossing
a lot of these areas that you've worked
in and it's touching on a lot of
different aspects that are increasingly
present sort of in the national
narrative
let's start for people who don't know
what we're talking about what's
geoengineering so the idea of solar
geoengineering is the idea that humanity
might deliberately make the earth a
little bit more reflective by some
technological means like putting some
kind of aerosol a fine dust into the
stratosphere perhaps and that that would
partially and imperfectly and in
permanently offset some of the risks the
climate risks that come from the
accumulation of carbon dioxide of the
atmosphere and is this just in terms of
preventing temperature increases or are
there other potential benefits certainly
not just temperature climate change
there's a whole host of things from
changes in extreme temperature changes
in rainfall patterns changes in sea
level changes in the impacts on the
natural environment on species and and
ecosystems and the evidence which is
certainly comes with lots of uncertainty
but the evidence is that a moderate
amount of solar to measuring something
that's a cut the overall rate of climate
change or warming if you like in half
would reduce changes both in temperature
but also reduce changes increases in
precipitation perhaps increase reducing
the increase in extreme storms that are
the things particularly destructive to
the poorest people in the world
specifically how would this be done in
other words what would be the sort of
technological mechanisms that would be
used to carry out such a policy so in
some ways that's the easiest part the
hard questions are mostly all about
govern
since science well we'll get to that I
think it's yeah exactly but I think it's
reasonably clear that at least in this
one method putting aerosols in the
stratosphere that really existing
technology essentially existing aircraft
technologies could be used to put say
you know some amount that will wrap up
from zero gradually to maybe over a sort
of 25 or 50 years to something like a
million tons of Europe material going
into the stratosphere and that that
could be done really with off-the-shelf
aircraft technology that many nations
could access and could be supplied by
many vendors so variants of the
technology that you see in a business
jet nothing all that fancy so the basic
ability to get my girl so stratosphere
is something that can be done it cost
them aren't very different from the cost
of shipping materials by era Freight
across the Pacific one of the criticisms
that I've read of this type of
geoengineering is that although it might
be effective in terms of the mitigation
of climate change that there are all
sorts of other negative potential
environmental repercussions depending on
what specifically is used as an aerosol
have the developments accelerated in
terms of solving that issue over the
last several years versus maybe in the
early 90s when there were earlier
discussions of this technology I think
the big perspective here is that because
of concerns some I think very well
founded and legitimate and some may be a
little bit kind of at the gut level
because of concerns about this
technology there isn't a large organized
research program so for example although
the United States is often seen as a
place of sort of technological optimism
justifiably so and though there's a huge
overall budget for climate research of
several billion the year not counting
all the money that we spend and we
should spend much more in my opinion on
cutting emissions
there has been no organized US
government research on any kind consoler
dream of sharing and very little
globally there's small research programs
now and in Europe and China and some in
the US I helped to run one but they're
funded dominantly by philanthropic money
these stars is because there's been very
very little
money so that the important answer at
this point is that we don't know very
much there's there's plenty and I can
tell you someone we do know but to be
clear the argument that I and I think
many people like me are making is not
that we ought to do Gino missionary I
think that would be ridiculous the
argument is that we ought to have a
serious coordinated open-access yorkers
program to understand more about how
well would work what the risks are
outlet controlling on the internet if
you were to for example prepare with an
inter for an interview with someone like
you and research geoengineering you
would inevitably come across all sorts
of conspiracy theories about
geoengineering sometimes the term
climate engineering is used you will
then probably go down the internet
rabbit hole into chemtrails and i've
interviewed one or two of the the
chemtrails conspiracy theories how did
this start
that geoengineering became so tied into
some of the I guess I would call them
not at not making a value judgment but
merely from the way that that the
material is presented some of the
juiciest conspiracy theories on the
Internet how did this develop I don't
know is the short answer I think from
what I understand there were long held
beliefs by probably a very tiny number
of people that the u.s. government was
sort of deliberately manipulating the
ionosphere through something called the
HARP program which was actually a pretty
normal nerdy physics program to try and
beam microwaves into the ionosphere and
and a bunch of related programs that
people who kind of want to see some
nefarious coordinated action imagined
were happening and then as the more
public discussion of solar generation
began to be more visible say a decade
ago those two ideas were somehow
conflated I don't know why what I think
is clear is that the extraordinary
spread of social media has really
changed the way these things work
so that there's much more you know it's
much easier to produce fake news as
we've seen in in lots of countries
including the US on last few years it's
much easier to produce materials that
appear too naive viewers to be
convincing and so you can get many more
people falling into the trap of
believing stuff that you know
objectively to the mainstream seems
really bizarre and and extraordinarily
unlikely to be true to it and that's
true on all sorts of of cases but this
is certainly a particularly odd one and
it stirs up a pretty high level of
hatred and anger in the Internet and I
think it probably will affect the kind
of normal discussion of Geo sharing
which itself is controversial but in
totally different ways let's talk now a
little bit about the sort of politics
and governance issues around this I mean
certainly I think we can all imagine how
if you go up into the sky and you start
spraying aerosols or whatever it is
ultimately used those aerosols are not
going to respect to these imaginary
lines on maps called country borders so
logistically who needs to agree to such
a program what are the sort of
governance obstacles that that would be
presented that's a very hard question
it's it's a it's an emerging question I
mean for all of these global public
goods and I think that's ultimately what
this is if it makes any sense
including goods that of course like any
of them have some risks and side effects
the way we manage them is in emerging as
it was a work in progress so that's true
from managing pollution of the ozone
layer it's true for matching global
climate it's true for for managing
infectious diseases and all sorts of
things so there isn't a simple formula
for what's legitimate obviously
international organizations matter but
soda coalitions of individual countries
and I think it will be some mixture of
what some individual countries do what
environmental groups or other
transnational public organizations do
and and what the internationalization is
like the United Nations do so it's
really hard to guess what I think is
really hopeful is that our are now
serious emerging efforts to look at what
at how that governess would work so for
example a guy called Janos pasture who
is the lead advisor to the Secretary
General for climate is now running an
effort to try and develop governance for
solar gene engineering one of the
concerns that I have that I know is
shared by at least some people in my
audience with regard to whatever we may
ultimately decide to do to try to deal
with human caused climate change is that
rather than taking a development like
geoengineering or a new form of energy
whatever the case may be in saying ok
now we can use this to actually make a
net improvement to what we're doing to
the climate that it will be seen at
least by some as sort of carte blanche
to keep doing exactly what we're doing
right saying hey now instead of just
improving the situation we'll keep doing
what we're doing but we won't be doing
as much damage because we've come up
with this new thing how do we deal with
that well I mean I think that is the the
central fear that it beyond any other
has held that researching this topic and
and I think there's ways in which it's
both deeply legitimate and and some ways
that it's less so so yeah of course
there will be some interests interest
for example in parts of the fossil fuel
industry they would like to keep the
party going and not reduce the fossil
fuel consumption the hard truth is that
if you want to stable climate you have
to bring fossil fuel consumption to zero
eventually and nothing about solar do
you measure any changes that you must
bring emissions to zero in a net solar
generation can reduce the risks of
climate change for co2 it's already in
the air but it can't eliminate them and
so I think it's certainly true that some
forces allied with say the fossil fuel
industry that doesn't want to see
hundred regulation might use the
possibility of solar geoengineering as
an excuse for inaction but
the question is how powerful those
forces really be in the end the
political forces that want to see our
climate protected need to win anyway and
I think gradually we we are beginning to
win we are beginning to win the battle
to restrict co2 emissions and I don't
think that adding something that further
reduces perhaps significantly reduces
the risks to the most vulnerable in the
planet which is what solar generation
could do I don't think that in the long
game that suddenly means that we lose
the political ability to cut emissions
but I agree it's a legitimate and hard
question all right something we will be
dealing with certainly for years to come
we've been speaking with David Keith
professor of engineering and of public
policy at Harvard University thanks so
much for talking to us about this thanks
a lot it's great to be on your show